Speaker 1: Ron DeSantis now leads Donald
Trump in the 2024 betting markets. Now,
as I as I always do, because I don't want any
confusion on this. These are not polls. These
are people betting. Who do you believe will be the
Republican presidential nominee? And although the
numbers themselves have fluctuated, the money is
behind DeSantis and Trump almost exclusively. The
next person down is Nikki Haley. And she's
almost nowhere. She's she's in the toilet,
right. To use the language that these folks use.
And it has been a head to head between Trump
and DeSantis. Trump leading that for much of the
last year, but it is now for many days straight.
And every day since the 2022 midterm has been
decent. DeSantis. DeSantis. Now, I don't believe
for a second that this proves DeSantis will be the
nominee. And in fact, one of the things I think.
Is important to think realistically about is do
we really believe that in a national campaign,
if it's the Trump of 20 sixteens Republican
primary, with the insults and the aggressiveness
and the attacks and the ridiculing of the
other candidates, do we really think that
in a national race, DeSantis can actually
stand up to the bully Trump? DeSantis To me,
although he is a horrible person. Wrong on most
issues. Completely disagree with him politically,
all these different things. I don't actually
know that dissent is can get down in the mud
down in the toilet water with Trump the way you
probably need to in order to actually defeat
Donald Trump in a far in a hard fought primary.
I don't know the answer yet one way or the other.
So the importance and the interest in looking at
these betting numbers relates to the things we're
going to look at next on the show, which include
other prominent Republicans turning on Trump media
outlets, turning on Trump this election and the
disaster of Trump's failed critical contested
endorsements. And we'll give you the list again
later. Many of you know the list already. It has
opened the door for many Republicans and media
outlets to just say, this is my opportunity to
turn on Donald Trump. So the numbers right now
in polling, we actually don't have new 2024
Republican nominee polling since the election.
We'll have it maybe tomorrow or Wednesday. And
it'll be interesting to look at in the betting
markets. In the betting markets, the favor has
turned towards Ron DeSantis over Donald Trump. And
that informs what we are going to talk about next.